joining us from Leicester to discuss his
knee shadow health secretary John
Ashworth there very good morning to you
mr. Ashworth good morning um the last
time we spoke I was perhaps slightly
cheeky I asked you what Labor's position
on brexit was at that week I've learned
my lesson we won't be doing that anymore
but I want to deal with the question of
No No Deal brexit Emily Thornbury has
today reiterated comments she made on
the show last week that we appear to be
heading for an ordeal brexit the Labour
Party has made it pretty clear that if
they had the opportunity that they would
vote against any No Deal why is that
because we don't think a so-called No
Deal where we simply crash out of the EU
and therefore have to adopt all the
World Trade Organisation tariff regimes
it's in the interests of British
business and the interests of British
farming we've got to export to the EU
and imposing some of the very high
tariffs that will inevitably have to
adopt we don't think is in our interest
so that's why we have-we have spoken out
against em and no deal actually the
government have said in the House of
Commons that they're no deal posture is
a negotiating tactic completely
undermining its ability to negotiate to
use it as a tactic that just shows you
how hapless the government's approach is
to brucks it but no deal doesn't
necessarily mean no agreement whatsoever
I mean it could also look like agreement
on the exit bill you know an answer to
the Northern Ireland port a question you
know agreement on on EU Nationals it
could essentially be agreement on
everything apart from trade I mean if
that were the case what's the problem
with going to WTO rules well I mean if
there were agreements on all those other
things then there's a and then there is
a deal of sauce but we would obviously
have to study the details of that which
is why we're we are saying that
Parliament has to have the final say
anything it's rather ironic that we have
the very sort of rabid brexit ears on
the Tory side saying just get on with it
I thought brexit was all about bringing
sovereignty back to Parliament so we
believe in those those sets of
circumstances Parliament would have to
say but obviously would have to study
very carefully the details of all that
before we come to a final two
what you just mentioned their Parliament
having the final say mean essentially
confirms that a line that the Liberal
Party's been putting out for quite some
time so we we now understand the labor
position to be you will vote against any
No Deal brexit you could also vote
against what you see as a bad brexit why
is that because a bad brexit is not in
the is not an industrial interest why
should we support a brexit deal which
means that hardworking families here in
my Leicester constituency and across the
country are worse off we're in the
business of improving the prosperity of
families not making families worse off
and if the outcome of this government's
negotiations is a deal which which means
the British economy suffers that's not
something we're going to accept we want
to strengthen the British economy you
know a strong economy means it means we
can invest in public services like our
NHS and our schools so that's what we
want a strong economy we don't want
brexit to weaken our economy and if
that's what the reason may comes up with
then I've got to say that's not going to
be in the end in the national interest
but there will be plenty of people
listening to what you've just said this
morning mr. Ashworth you see there's
something about of an abrogation of the
democratic responsibility I mean we're
in that question that was posed to the
British people back in June 2016 was
there any mention of this that the UK
should leave the EU only a sake astara
thinks it's a good deal it was a simple
question about being in or being out the
rest of the responsibility was handed to
the government there's been a national
poll of the country since that
referendum we had a general election
campaign and other Tories don't like to
be reminded of that general election
campaign now on all of us in our
personal manifestos when we stood for
election said we would oppose any deal
which was not in the national interest
so we have had a democratic vote on that
position since the referendum well
here's the thing so labour is saying
that it will vote down an ordeal brexit
you vote down anything that you believe
to be a bad deal if you if you won't
accept either of those options that
there is one that remains you know
staying in the European Union the reason
we are involved in politics the reason
why we put ourselves forward
for elected office is because we're
optimists we do we believe that you know
change is possible I'm perfectly
confident that we can get a good deal we
can get a deal which is in the interests
of British families and British business
and the British economy I'm just very
very pessimistic that this this Prime
Minister who is missing excruciating
watching her Premiership it really is
being ripped apart isn't it and we're
just very pessimistic that she can get a
deal in the national interest but we're
in politics because we think getting
good for our constituents and getting
and strengthening our economy is
possible so asterix worth it I don't
think it's an either/or I don't think I
don't think it's ad I don't think it's a
bad deal or stay and I think we can get
a good deal if every week since we've
spoken there has been a revision or
softening further detail as to you know
Labour's position and bricks I mean how
must long must we wait before labour
actually starts being honest and talks
about what a number of people in your
back benches are talking about they're
not the front bench yeah second
referendum I'm entirely honest entirely
honest we've outlined our position we
think that for example there should be
some transitional arrangements
interestingly that we set that and then
a few weeks later to resume copied us in
her Florence speech and said it as well
so I think actually we're leading the
debate we're leading the argument on
these matters and we're being entirely
honest with the British people we accept
that the referendum came to a conclusion
that we should leave the European Union
but that doesn't mean we shouldn't try
and get the very best deal for the
British economy I don't think the two
positions are contradictory as with
brexit and the Labour Party doesn't
disagree in principle with with
Universal Credit can you outline why in
that opposition deed debate you were you
were calling for a pause because we the
rollout of it is it's not very
satisfactory is it I mean people have to
wait six weeks we all of us in our
constituencies are getting examples from
various advice bureaus and food banks
and so on of the of the impact that
Universal Credit is going to have on
people we know that people of there's
many part examples across the country of
people being evicted of people going
into huge rent arrears and it's causing
real hardship now when Universal Credit
was first and
right Ian Duncan Smith we did agree
agreed with the principle and still do
agree with the principle but since then
there's been cuts to the different
elements of universal credit which means
it's actually going to plunge people
into poverty poverty is going to
increase under universal credit and one
of the big selling points of universal
credit when in Duncan Smith Blue
unveiled it he said that it was going to
be a great anti-poverty initiative so
there's been lots of cuts and changes to
the design of universal credit over the
last few years which we think is really
going to hurt our constituents which is
why we brought that motion to the House
of Commons the torah' didn't have the
courage of the convictions they vanished
they scarpered which by the way if our
constituents didn't turn up to the
Jobcentre that'd be sanctioned for it
and it really was quite extraordinary
and I must say this when we had
opposition day motions under a Labour
government I remember we lost one on
Gurkhas Damien Green who is now the
Deputy Prime Minister effectively stood
up in the House of Commons and said the
house that the will of the house was
clear he was making a big fuss about the
opposition beating the government in
that opposition day motion and now 10
years down the line Tory MPs cannot be
even be bothered to vote on these
motions
it's really quite disgraceful mr.
Ashworth were heading into winter
traditionally the most difficult time
for the NHS I mean how confident are you
in the services ability to cope suddenly
I'm not very confident at all we're now
in a situation where every single target
in the hospital sector in the ambulance
sector is being missed and you've got to
remember that these are targets which
have been weakened under the Tory
government they were much tougher
targets under a Labour government and we
used to meet them I mean the NHS is
going through the biggest financial
squeeze in its history indeed on the
current figures next year head for head
across England and money will actually
be falling it'll actually be cut so what
I'm saying is ahead of the budget you
know put extra money into the NHS I deal
with the extra money in addition to the
extra money that you want to see you
know to increase public sector pay
particularly your in your brief in the
Health Service well indeed they cannot
they cannot find the money for the
public sector pay increase from existing
NHS budgets if they do that that would
be incredibly unfair and it will mean
wider cuts across the NHS but they've
also got to deal with the social care
crisis
we're bringing a motion for the House of
Commons this week on Social Care calling
on the government's to reverse the cuts
to Social Care put the money into social
care that is needed at the moment the
government are saying they're going to
cut Social Care budgets that they give
to local authorities when actually
because the local authorities have been
unable to deal with some of what they
call in the system delayed discharges of
cares basically unable to cope with
getting people the social care packages
they need on time we think cutting local
authority budgets penalizing them for
that is no way to solve the social care
crisis so we're calling on the
government this week in the House of
Commons to deal with social care
resource we'll wait and see if the Tory
MP is actually bothered to turn up to
that as well but you know listen I'm so
sorry but we're gonna leave it there we
are literally just out of time many
thanks for being with us